on the mound for the marlins it is sandy
alcantara this is his fifth start of the
season coming off and no decision
against the phillies marlins got their
first walk-off win that night well one
guy to watch out for in this lineup is
at the plate right now rafael devers
here saying he's got him set up 02 and
he goes 99 miles an hour actually split
the plate and just blew it by him with
two strikes
there you go tanner moments away from
his first big league pitch what a moment
for this young man yeah you know he's
feeling it so aguilar next 295 with six
home runs 3-2 and down he goes that was
96 miles an hour quick inning to start
his big league career
bring up bobby dalbeck's kid is off to
an unbelievable start sandy kicks fires
and that pitches in on the hands swung
on a miss strike three in a very quick
and easy good inning of work for sandy
alcantara that's his second strikeout
and he got the side in order one two
three nothing nothing game in the bottom
of the fourth in miami
struck out again that one ate him up he
fans for the second time and that is six
in the book for the youngster you know
the range of his fastball has gone from
that 92 up to as high as what 96. that
had great movement on it 92 miles an
hour well good at bat here for miguel
rojas he has a lot of them this is the
eighth pitch of the a b with two men on
and he struck him out made a terrific
pitcher barking it himself seven punch
outs for hauck and after four zero two
sandy had five innings and three hits a
walk and four strikeouts to this point
rafael devers but here he comes up empty
98 miles an hour an elevated fastball
from sandy that's five strikeouts yeah
maybe saving a little something for
the third trip through the lineup he's
fan five so far tonight so a couple of
base runners here for jackie here's
pitch number 90.
stung the other way and that's going to
get down and keep on going all the way
to the wall that's going to score xander
bogarts in for the first run tonight
down to second jackie bradley jr vazquez
into third and the red sox have a one
nothing lead
finally against miami jackie takes that
fastball almost out of the glove the
other way i'll tell you when jackie does
that he looks like a real good hitter
right down the left field line that is
money
that ball too is probably about three
inches off the outside part of the plate
he covered it beau got scores vasquez to
third and jackie in the second base so
the deadlock is broken pitchers duel
tonight red sox leading one to nothing
trying to pad the lead as rafael devers
leads off first pitch swinging drives
one to deep right that ball is off the
wall on the fly
played back in by matt joyce it'll be an
easy lead off double for rafael devers
his first hit of the night he's now one
for four and that'll be it for blyer we
expected to see the marlins bring the
right-hander in for bogarts either way
but now uh it's even more vital james
hoyt into the ball game a leadoff double
for rafael devers against richard bleyer
19th game for hoyt this year at 159 era
we keep telling you this has been his
role coming in when there are runners on
base as jd martinez he's over three and
one for his last 28. boy does he need a
big hit play on that's going to go off
into the outfield devers is up and
running he is heading into 30 dives in
there
and he's safe
and the red sox have a man at third base
and a misfire by hoyt he didn't have
that big a lead either they were going
to put it on
something that's unnecessary woozy two
feet off the back right
just hanging on to that bag with the
toes and the 2-2 from white
swing little flare center field charging
out of marte down for a base hit that'll
bring in the run
raffy devers scores
not hit hard but it was hit in the right
spot the red sox lead it two nothing
yeah he hit it like he threw it pretty
much same
he hit it like he threw it and he
crunched him too the end of the bat
stayed back as long as he could flicked
it out there just waiting to see if it's
going to drop in in front of that center
field
and it did
so the red sox with
just a little bit of wiggle room now on
top two nothing on the rbi single by
vasquez his 15th rbi all smiles after
that ryan brazier to pop into the ball
game he becomes the second hurler
chisholm has gone over two
he'll knock that one pretty well hit
muno is on the run and a leaping play
and into the fence he held on
took a shot there he he's slow to rise
but a fine running leaping catch and
munoz hangs on johan quezada his major
league debut was on saturday against the
phillies
and finally quezada puts away munoz for
the first out of the night
now at least nine to get through verdugo
payoff pitch
ground ball is this it rojas chisholm
over to first a double play no runs and
will go to the bottom of the ninth the
marlins trail two to nothing so now it
is up to matt barnes coming out of the
bullpen marlins have been held to three
hits by the red sox pitching staff
swaying and a miss on a breaking ball he
struck him out and that does it tanner
hawk becomes the first red sox started
to win his major league debut since 2015
red sox in the win column tonight two
nothing